on va faire une pause musicale comme à
chaque fois dans cette émission et on va
retrouver bon gars qui interprète qui ça
nous sans goût c'est un extrait de son
dernier album monôme bulambo sango là
ils seront en concert au new morning le
12 octobre prochain donc de son nom
original c'est barcelo d'écart vaio qui
est dit bong à quenza il est né dans la
province de bengo en angola d'une mère à
airoise et d'un père angolais il a fait
de la musique très très jeune et il
écrivait des chansons il disait une
musique qui ne plaisait pas forcément
aux autorités angolaises dont il a
longtemps été en exil aux pays bas ce
n'est que récemment qu'il a pu rejoindre
son pays on écoute donc bon gars qui
s'aiment ou sans vous
donc au passage il a du coup la lame
enfants
vous êtes un bon moment
je
didier baffou tulou loud
encore
il va
monfils en paille à internet
c'est sympa
nous
beaucoup partagent ils à lyon
on à la mouche
qu'obama gilles agniel pour l'abandon
de jenson
des capitaux
brian a d'ailleurs
voilà on a tenu bon gars qu'on a
enregistrées cet après midi donc extrait
de l'album mulamba deux angles là on
retrouve à tout à l'heure pour un autre
titre de cet album